- La journée de Liam n'est pas
ce qu'elle devait être.
LIAM VALAY-CHOINIÈRE
- Dès que je me suis levé
et que j'ai regardé ma montre,
j'ai remarqué que comme,
il n'y avait pas d'école.
- Celle de sa mère non plus.
SARAH VALAY-NADEAU, mère de Liam
- Pas un autre cas de COVID?
J'ai dit non, non, là,
c'est la grève, mon gars,
tu peux retourner te coucher.
- Je les comprends parce que
comme l'école, je sais que
ça ne paie pas beaucoup.
- Pas de travail pour la maman,
pas de fête costumée
pour les enfants.
- Ce n'était pas la meilleure
des journées parce qu'il y a
deux trucs spécials : le gymnase
puis l'Halloween à l'école.
(klaxons)
- 20 000 travailleurs de l'État
ont voté, ces dernières
semaines, en faveur de mandats
de grève. 5000 d'entre eux,
des agents correctionnels,
des chauffeurs d'autobus,
des employés des traversiers
et de l'éducation, notamment,
l'ont mis à exécution.
Lundi, 5000 autres pourraient
s'ajouter.
DOMINIC CARDY,
ministre de l'Éducation, N.-B.
- C'est un choix aujourd'hui
de commencer cette grève,
un choix d'impacter le système
d'éducation et un choix
d'impacter le système de santé.
- Au coeur du litige :
les augmentations de salaire.
35 millions $ séparent
les parties sur un budget
provincial de 10 milliards $.
Blaine Higgs a promis
de redresser les finances
de la province, l'une des plus
pauvres du pays.
- Moi, je n'ai pas envie
que ce soit fermé 2-3 semaines.
- Mauvaise nouvelle
pour Sarah et les parents
de 100 000 jeunes
néo-brunswickois :
- Toutes les écoles : nord, sud,
est, ouest, français, anglais
vont passer à l'apprentissage
à domicile lundi, et ça va
continuer jusqu'à la fin
de la grève.
- Le gouvernement ferme
les écoles et pourrait recourir
à l'adoption d'une loi spéciale
pour les travailleurs
non essentiels de la santé,
par exemple.
- Je trouve ça dommage de ne pas
être allée travailler
parce qu'avec les fermetures
COVID puis tout ça, on a de la
difficulté à prendre un rythme.
- Même s'ils aiment
la trottinette, ses enfants
veulent aller à l'école,
en personne.
- Bien, je lui ai dit :
retourne à la table puis vite,
parce que nous autres,
on a besoin que les écoles
soient ouvertes.
Nos enfants, ils ont besoin
de ça, puis ça va faire,
le niaisage, là. Donnez-leur
leur contrat, puis je choisis
mes mots gentiment.
- Pour le moment,
aucune rencontre n'est prévue
entre les parties.
Ici Maude Montembeault,
Radio-Canada, Moncton